how to begin a cryptic crosswords with
expert advice from Ashley nose aka boat
man what is it about cryptic crosswords
messages to a secret agent a manual on
how to build an alien spacecraft the
ramblings of a lunatic cryptic clues do
mean something they're just not what
they seem there's always one way to read
a clue that will tell you what to do
most cryptic clues have two parts one
part teasingly defines the solution the
other part is a playful way to get to
the same thing but which is which
[Music]
is this about finding transports or
boats let's guess it's about transport
and see what the rest of the clue could
mean what fish do we know and boats hang
on we know what a car park is sometimes
keywords will tell you what to do look
out for anagram indicators sound alike
indicators which are often phrases you
just need to learn to recognize
[Music]
or reversal indicators and don't give up
remember the person who set the
crossword wants you to solve it
he or she may play the part of an evil
genius torturing the hero who enters
their lair but you are bond and bond
always wins and you may even learn some
new words along the way thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon